my latest guest on this voices of the
nfl
collection of just getting started
podcasts we've already had al michaels
on and joe buck and this man is somebody
who i met
way back in the day when he was a mere
new york football giant trying for a
sack record eventually and a
trajectory of a hall of fame career path
and now he joins me as as a pro football
hall of famer but also a good morning
america co-anchor
uh a men's clothier let me see what else
i've got here i've also got hold on a
second an nfl on fox analyst an
occasional game show host and one of the
top television producers in sports and
of course also documentaries his show in
season two with spring hill
entertainment more than an athlete is on
espn plus he is michael strahan how are
you straight
i'm good man how are you i am no rich
eisen but i'm okay did i get that all
right did i get that done yeah yeah yeah
yeah you got it all down man i
appreciate it that's all the time i have
that's all the time i have thanks for
joining me michael you know it's been a
pleasure
hey but um you know i love what you're
doing here though and the names that you
have the people that you have ladies and
gentlemen thank you that you have coming
on it's real i'm honored
to be considered to be in that group oh
gosh well you're you're a voice of the
nfl and obviously having an a hall of
fame playing career and
there are so many and obviously you you
host an aptly named show as well as
produce it more than an athlete uh on
espn plus because you are the model i
mean you are
what so many players perhaps are going
through right now in the nfl wondering
can they do what you're doing what you
have done
since hanging them up and that's part of
the reason why i also wanted to have you
on here straight is not only because i
consider you a friend but i i what
you've done is beyond i mean impressive
isn't even the word
so how did it start like literally like
what did it start with you getting an
idea like i can talk for a living
because you were in the new york market
i mean like literally what where did
this all begin where you
started to piece this together
michael i think i think it's part of
that i think being in the new york
market like i i am not blind to the fact
of where i played football definitely
helped me
um
you know i could have this career
somewhere else and it probably wouldn't
have been as big of a deal or i wouldn't
have the same opportunities that i had
but being in new york and always being
asked to do interviews and be on shows
and i said yes because not because i
looked at it as a career i just looked
at it as i can have fun like i'm talking
to people it's about sports it's about
whatever how hard could that be
and then as i as i played and i kept
doing more of it i start to understand
more about the media i understood more
how it worked i understood more how to
um
you know as much as the the media uses
you after a game or during the week to
get quotes and all these things
use your power to better yourself with
them
i so i i did little things like i would
restrict my immediate access when i was
a player to be honest with you i would
just talk twice a week
and that way i knew whenever i did say
something you were gonna use it it was
important um i also
knew that by being in new york and i
doing all these different things that i
went on best dance sports show period i
started doing uh i did a super bowl for
abc not i wasn't even really getting
paid for these things but it was like
it's fun i never looked at it as a
career post football
until my last two years in the league
when i realized
you know it's coming to an end there's
something else that i could be doing and
some opportunity started coming my way
and i worked for every network
as a player so i decided that i wanted
to go to fox because fox was probably
the loosest
it was um the more more fun
in a lot of ways less football more
entertainment and that was important to
me because um i i looked at myself and
you said i'm more than an athlete i just
want to feel like i'm somewhere where i
can actually talk sports but also have
personality doing it and fox gave me
that opportunity so yeah it began
organically just doing interviews and
having fun in new york
the next thing you know i i got a job
and i realized two years before my
career ended that i could make a living
do you know make a living job and work
you just use those words
because
when somebody
does what you're doing
and you make it look easy because you
are having fun right you're having fun
you're being yourself which is
one of the goals in this industry in
this business is to
is to do that and it's not it's not
every day where you do get to do that
but it's a job
it's work man
it is work you know it is an absolute
slog sometimes to do all this the times
that you do get up that you do i mean
good morning america is great but that
alarm clock goes off and you've just
done a sunday on fox and your phone
calls i'm sure i'm sure your phone is
ringing the minute you get off the set
with the other things that i i i did to
start all this so why yeah why like
literally why you know why because i
mean
i can do it it's a challenge
it's a challenge i i
you're right it is a job and i got i
have to do some things sometimes i don't
want to do when i don't want to do it i
have to wake up every day i have to
basically ask permission to take a
vacation because i'm i'm working for
some big corporate companies and and and
that's what people don't see
but the payoff at the end of it is more
than worth it because the payoff to me
has been the fact of being able to do
something
that i never thought i could do that a
lot of other people probably never
thought i could do
and that we in a lot of ways we haven't
seen done before by somebody who came
off of the football field or whatever
the athletic field so that is a driver
in itself of me to try to see how far
i can push it how far i can go because i
realize for me the further i go it's
kind of like opened up the door for more
athletes to go any further even further
than what was a allotted to us before so
that's really my motivating factor and i
like the discipline of it i like the
football was scheduled it was routine
for a while i would just do fox and have
seven months off and i'm sitting around
and then i gotta hang out with jay
glazer all the time i mean geez who
wants to do that so i had
to i had to find something else to do
and i was always interested in business
rich you know i came to football late as
a senior in high school so i never
looked at it as football was the only
thing that i could do and i think
because of that mindset it's allowed me
to like not be
not not handicapped myself for not feel
like i put myself in such a box that
this is it and that's all i'm more like
okay football with the start as the box
is wide open no end no sides on the box
just go and fill the box instead of
having the box tell you what you can put
in it you put as much as you can into
that box and i do it because i love it
man it's so much fun i i don't have a
bad job and i really mean that i do not
have a job that i go to in the morning
even gma early and think i don't want to
be here i get there and i am energized
i'm excited because i know i'm going to
learn something i know every day is
different news changes and i'm sitting
next to professionals who've done this
forever and i'm learning from them too
and i'm nervous
fox fox i don't get so nervous anymore
pyramid i don't get nervous um
jimmy
i get nervous i absolutely it's it's
so far out of the wheelhouse it's news
and it's about information and it's
about being well read it's about really
knowing your stuff it's about conveying
what the audience wants asking the
question the audience wants to ask
setting the tone and what in which is
appropriate for each story that you
deliver
and not making it about yourself
and the football player is all about you
oh what do you think about this you go
well i think that you're always being
asked questions the hardest thing for
guys
and i tell them this all the time if you
want to get into this business
especially outside of sports you have to
learn how to ask questions you have to
learn how to be curious you have to
really be interested in other people
because
we're just so used to everybody coming
to us and we just kind of going to relax
more and answer questions you have to
listen too when you ask the question and
you don't know the answer to it like for
instance just as a for instance uh a
couple of minutes ago you said that you
do things sometimes that you don't want
to do this podcast is not one of them
right no no no absolutely not no no you
you know what every time you call i'm
excited because i'm like man he's really
is my friend i love this guy
so absolutely it is a craft there's no
doubt about us asking questions and
listening to it and listening to the
answers as well but you got to work at
it too as well as you know and and i
remember watching so so many athletes at
least in my opinion when they were
retiring and get a job on tv they would
go there and say because i'm me that's
good enough
because they know my name that's good
enough
that that's not good enough
and i've always i've realized in
broadcasting and business especially um
your name gets you in the room
but your actions and your knowledge and
your abilities are what will keep you in
the room
and so i've always made sure if i step
into a room and if it's something i
really want to do i'm going in there of
course with a name and a face and a gap
in my teeth you know but
i'm gonna make sure that you know that i
belong in that room and i know what the
hell i'm talking about what i'm doing
and i think that is that is what guys
need to realize if anyone ever go wants
to go into this business
your name only carries you so far your
your skills and your actions your work
ethic is what what really helps the
branching out what was that big moment
or a meeting or or somebody or a piece
of advice or anything like that that
happened to you that really kick-started
everything
do you think
i think the
the kickstart to everything was
live with kelly and michael
absolutely it and that took it to
another level
um fox nfl sunday was
you know was definitely a level outside
of being a player because
i don't have a helmet on you know and so
many people watch football it's
ridiculous the numbers that of people
watch football but
that show put me in a different um in
front of a different set of eyeballs
they put me in front of mothers and
daughters and and and more women
uh and i think that that was just a very
important um
turning point for me
to get in front of that audience that my
life has like just
ever since then and that's why i'm
forever grateful for the show for
choosing me because when i first went on
i i had no child to get in that job they
didn't know anything about me and i
didn't know anything about how
morning television and daytime
television like that worked i i got that
job out of ignorance out of literally
saying i'm never going to get the job so
go have fun
figure it out as you go along
just an opportunity to try something
different and see where it goes but it
ended up being that you know that that
job that definitely changed the
trajectory of my career put me in a
different
stratosphere
when i guess you were use that word for
that i mean because regis chair
was easily i mean that's honestly that's
like that's kind of like up there with
the jeopardy gig
right now that's been kind of like that
is a
that is a that chair
on that morning show or that audience
it was aspirational to say the least
there's no there's no question about
that so
what was your first audition like for
that or you knew that you were trying
out or
you know what was that no no no no you
know what i went on i went crazy enough
i went on that show
after we won the super bowl and i wasn't
a guest now i know how the show works so
a guest they go through the monologue
um then they come up and they move the
the chair around and then they you know
introduce you after the commercial break
and you come out and you sit you i
thought a guest
i was like a walkout
it was during their opening they said
well we got this football player guy
come on out
everybody's their brother tried to call
me right now so um so i literally walked
out from
the side they had a little chair a
little stool they put next to kelly and
regis and kelly and i sit there and they
do this interview and i almost feel like
eli wasn't available so they said well
we got to get somebody wanting a super
bowl they're in new york we are new york
so we got to have somebody from the
giants
man and so i sit there and and regis
said what are you going to do now after
the super bowl if you want to retire and
i said well
if i retire i'm on a show right now
maybe okay michael michael and kelly if
you want to retire
just messing around
after the show we did tell gelman the
producer that if we just go on vacation
need somebody to fill in i would love to
fill in and i swear it was like a year
later or so he's on vacation and i get a
call okay come in
i went in the show went like that that
hour was damn gone
and
man
it was scary it was but it was so
exhilarating like
i loved it like the live audience the
energy of it the
the
the
don't be afraid to make a mistake
because that's part of live tv and the
hardest thing for most guys to do is be
yourself on tv and i don't i don't have
a problem with that i have no problem
with looking silly or yeah i'm very
comfortable with who i am man so to me
that show fit like a glove
and
after that i hope that that show gets
hosted at 20 times
and um
never did i necessarily think until the
last five times that okay i legitimately
have a shot at this job the first 15 i
went in and did it in hopes
um after about 10 i started hoping
because i loved it so much but i knew
there was no guarantee because my name
was probably the
least likely name to get picked to do it
because you had guys who've grown up in
this business who are more known for
that and why would they give it to me
because i'm the exact opposite of regis
in so many ways but i also think that's
why when i did join the show the show
was successful because i was the exact
opposite of regis
and exact opposite of kelly in a lot of
ways and we literally
from day one just had a chemistry that
it was was
natural
and and
and go ahead i'm sorry
yeah the rest is history and i but the
way it ended i think a lot of people
thought you know oh well i i but i tell
you i i just we just had the natural
chemistry on the show that if i went
back today i'm
pretty sure we could pick it up put on a
great show i just something about
she watching her and understanding how
she operated on that show and
understanding the space that she needed
on that show and what the role was it
was it was so comfortable i think um for
so uh that was the best learning
experience i've ever had
on tv yeah as far as like early mode
oh you know and then yeah it is i'll pay
you the
the compliment here straight and again
i i i honestly thought this the other
day and this is the truth
when i saw the video of you being
surprised on good morning america with
the fact that your number's going to be
retired by the way congratulations on
that
you are it's well deserved thank you
that it was on good morning america
where i'm used to seeing you now okay
i'm used to seeing you now
and eli popped out of that box
and your reaction to it was hilarious i
mean because that's what tv's all about
is just natural stuff and your natural
reaction which you're now a natural ad
but i honestly thought for a split
second
oh that's right he was a football player
literally that's what i thought
you know and and
um i should know clearly that you were a
football player but it's kind of like
part of your past
and not your current day which is what
is
what it's all about you know it's crazy
you say that i'll be honest with you say
that and i forget rich i i swear to you
i
forget i don't feel
like i've had that whole 15 years of it
too like it's not like it was i was in
the league for three years five years
and i came out you know got a career 15
freaking years a lifetime
in in football
and i forget because so much has
happened since then and and the eyeball
that are on me is so different now right
now i'm in my man cave and this is the
only place where i outside of the gym at
my house other than that i don't have
sports
paraphernalia anywhere
it's like i i have to hear my man cave
and i come here to remind myself that
one at one point i was great at
something i guess
but but
but it is funny because a lot of people
you have a generation of kids
they have no idea who i am they know me
as a tv guy or the game show guy or the
news guy they have no idea that i was
actually an athlete and it kind of
freaks me out because i'm looking at
them going
you don't know about football like you
know i could have saved myself a lot of
wear and tear on the body man if i just
wrapped it up a little bit earlier it
started just this tv thing
but it is amazing i've had i've been
very fortunate to have this career and
i've had great people who've helped me
great examples like yourself i mean
when you go way back and i remember when
you first went to the nfl network and
and just like watching you help build
the network
and and now understanding when building
shows and doing these things how hard it
is and how much pressure it is when
you're that guy and that's what you are
so watching you do what you do and how
you did it from one to the next that
helps guys like me because watching how
easy you are
makes me go okay what can i pick up from
rich
that can help me and and i think that's
what um
has helped me more is watching guys who
are great at what they do
and trying to figure out what part of
their greatness i can add to my
lifestyle and hopefully
try to even keep up on in any level to
them and you're one of those guys you're
very kind to say that straight i really
appreciate that um what's brady like as
a producing partner
tom's great man
you know what i love about tom i
appreciate about tom he doesn't want to
do it if it's not the best
absolutely
has to be the best the best quality the
best story uh he is he's uncompromising
and being the best
and even after their first win you know
the week one at that that great game
on thursday night
he's like hey i attacked him i said
great game and come back and his thing
is yep got to get better
i'm like uh
i said well you know the quest for you
know getting better and light on and off
the field never ends you know i'm trying
to sound philosophical because the guy
just basically told me thank you but no
thank you that's not good enough
and he's just always on the quest to be
the best
and that's how you as a producing
partner and as a business partner just
want to be the best in every way it's
stupid man that he's trying for eight
it's really dumb when you think about it
i mean like
you know when you're talking about when
nfl network first started in o3 it was
like four was the number you know
four four was the number when it was
about montana and your nfl on fox cohort
bradshaw that's the number yeah he's
going to double it this year and that's
insane double
it's insane though you know what and if
you're going to double it doubling the
wins
okay
the guy's been in 10.
he's been in 10 super bowls
and i just look and go i can't imagine
winning seven
but god i can't imagine being in 10. but
you got him though i wouldn't do two
and i was like
you're
yeah yeah yeah thank goodness because
had i not i mean i i may have had to go
back and play one more year to see if we
could actually pull it off again so
thank you for letting me retire um but
that was man i
i can't imagine the he deserves all the
accolades he gets he deserves to be
called the goat even though he doesn't
like it he deserves to um you know to
still be looking as great and throwing
as well as he does because he puts in
every ounce of work to make sure that he
can play like that and he's serious
about this diet he's serious about you
know playability and about the tb12
method he lives by what he says and the
hardest thing for me to understand truly
is that here the guy rich i knew at 36
15 years we won that super bowl
and even before that
i'm tired man i'm tired of pep talks
i'm tired of you know coming out of this
tunnel doesn't give me the same
exhilaration
and of course the super bowl did but i'm
like uh you know how much work it is to
get to that point
to have the mentality to do it for 22
years the same way
it's unbelievable to me i'm more amazed
at that in a lot of ways than i am by
10 super bowls and and going for number
eight just a mentality to be able to
compete and want to compete at that
level day in and day out there uh let's
in in wrapping this up clearly again as
we've just discussed i mean you got your
menswear you've got um you know the
pyramid you've got gma you've got fox
you've got
so many different things i mean honestly
there's only 24 hours in a day
why uh do the show you're doing with
espn plus with spring hill entertainment
i know i guess we've kind of
covered the ground a little bit here
about you being more than an athlete but
why why this
project
michael
because
first of all i i i love the fact of
working with other athletes so
and helping help another guy and helping
each other right so this team up with
spring hill the team up with lebron team
up with maverick
was a big deal because i think you know
just teaming up and showing athletes
working together to create things
themselves is really important i also
i think a lot of people look rich like
you said oh he played football
but and you knew that but there are so
many people who think that i just showed
up and played football then i just said
hey broadcast tv i'm here put me on and
they put me on
yeah
but it's not that way there was so much
growing up and i had to go through
in every facet of my life that
i just want people to see that not so
much for seeing and knowing me better in
a lot of ways but so much for hopefully
seeing themselves
at some point in my journey so that they
understand that hey
okay it wasn't always easy for him oh i
felt that way before oh i've been
uncomfortable before i've been rejected
before i've been applauded before and a
lot of things is like how do you handle
not just failure but how do you handle
success
both are equally important how do you
treat people um
how do you conduct your your day-to-day
life personally and professionally and i
just want people to see that no matter
what keep pushing if you have a dream
don't let anybody stop you from it
surround yourself with people who want
to build you up not people want to tear
you down and most of all you will doubt
yourself more than anyone else will ever
doubt you
and you have to figure out how to
convince yourself that you can be as
great as you want to be more so than
expecting someone else to build you up
that's why it's called as cat william
said self-esteem the way i've been
ending all these interviews is asking
all these broadcasters um what's the
best piece of advice they've gotten in
their career so i'll ask that of you if
it's a in the broadcasting world
football world life world
anything what's the best piece of advice
that you've gotten michael string here
man
robin roberts gave me the best piece of
advice
when it when it comes to like like i
said gma's the toughest thing i've ever
done robin roberts at the oscars on the
red carpet i'm working for live at that
time and i am scared to death rich this
is hollywood this is big stars black tie
the oscars man who i watched that i'm
not supposed to be on that red carpet
can't even use the words that i wasn't
saying when i said scared right and i
see robin
and i see robin this scared shitless
there we go
and i see robin across the way
and i ways the waves i go over to see
her
and she looked at me and she go how you
feeling i go robin i'm i'm scared scared
she goes
hey you got this
you got this don't worry
i came from sports too you belong here
completely completely
changed my life with that one little
thing you ca i i saw robin roberts
knowing that she came where i came from
and knowing how i didn't even recognize
that because she's so great at what she
does now
and then to say you belong here meant
the world to me and that's why i run
through a wall for her any day of the
freaking week and and so you know
that was the best piece of advice i've
gotten and then i've created a little
saying that i tell myself when it comes
to life and making decisions report the
news
don't be the news
[Laughter]
report the news don't be the news i
liked it yeah that's it man you have no
idea how upset people were
that they thought you got rid of your
gap tooth you have no idea man you have
no idea
yes i do rich you know why because
social media lets you know man and i
tell you what
i did it i had so many people man i felt
bad to come out and say i didn't do it
because i did have a lot of people who
were like you know what you do you
i'm so proud of you and i always wanted
to do it now you've given me strength to
do it like i've inspired a lot of you i
felt really bad
but then you had all those people who
were like okay believe you you left you
let out you let down the gap nation and
i'm like since when the hell is there a
gap nation i would never gotten a job i
never got card for that or you know who
who started who you know i'm not a
charter member so it was like so many
people were so pissed
that for those people i was glad i
didn't do it but for the people who were
sincere and nice i apologize
and i literally had people for months
when i would smile would be like oh you
didn't fix it like obviously you didn't
see the second video
there's an april fool's gag and and the
number of times i've accused erlacker of
leaving me on the battlefield because he
got his hair you know what i've accused
dion sanders a prime i tell prime you've
left me on you've left me behind in the
bro like
you used to be part of the brotherhood
you're not anymore and dion who refers
to himself as the comeback player of the
year he keeps telling me he he told me
that my wife you know susie she really
deep deep down she wants me to get the
hair he dion said it was like
we're double dutching and susie's got
one end of the rope and she's kind of
looking at me saying come on in here
come on you know and she's just by
herself that's dion saying she's double
dutching by herself and so i
i have on occasion i have ever thought
about it but i i don't know i kind of
think to myself like i'm not going to be
true to myself if i do it
um and i go back and forth but i'm
i don't know i'm i i i always feel like
i i'd get people saying you left me
behind you know but then there's other
just you be you be you make yourself
happy you look good either way man i
mean yeah no all right uh hey straight
there you go uh you're the best um
congrats on everything everyone should
watch uh more than an athlete's second
season on espn plus and then strand
everywhere else uh you're the best thank
you michael strahan the one and only
michael strahan and i i want to stress a
couple things here first of all the fact
that robin roberts
pulls him aside and acts in a
first-class
manner should surprise no one
i mean
i i i remember meeting robin roberts for
the first time i was 26 at espn
and
you know i showed up at espn
and it was dan patrick and keith
olbermann doing the 11 o'clock eastern
show the big show as it was known
and it was
um craig kilbourne and
[Music]
fill in the blank at
2 30 in the morning was the late night
the feel-good edition of sportscenter
and then there was the early edition of
sportszone the six o'clock eastern
edition of sportscenter which was kind
of like the nightly news version of
sportscenter and it was bob lee
nicknamed the general for generally
and charlie steiner and robin roberts
and
you know that was the grouping of people
that i was you know as a 26 year old
goofing around late at night doing the
sportscenter world
fun stuff
i was genuinely concerned if um i was
um offending them or
not being taken seriously by them if i
was potentially viewed by them as
defraying their part
their journalistic part
of the brand it's not like they didn't
have fun they they would have fun i mean
some of the most famous moments you
should google right now is charlie
steiner cracking up
during his reads about um
the
carl lewis doing the national anthem or
just look up charlie steiner and tanya
harding
and him
recounting
her breakup with jeff gillooly
her i think husband and just just google
that they had fun but not like late at
night and she could not have been nicer
and more accommodating and more
welcoming and just chill and cool
so that stroke part of the story about
strange doesn't surprise me
but the fact that he's talking about how
nervous he was about not being in a lane
in his lane
um
is
i think
very important to stress here
the fact that
he has that sort of self-awareness
is what in my mind
makes him highly successful one of the
many reasons along with a drive and a
sense of professionalism
that needs to be stressed here
because the number of former athletes
that i have worked with nfl players
obviously in particular over the last 18
years
who in many ways their careers end
in their careers and in their mid to
late 30s i mean stray mentioned he was
36. brady's the outlier at 44 or
whenever the heck he
is going to retire
but
you know
many nfl players
after hall of fame careers need to find
something else to do in their mid to
late 30s or even earlier than that
marshall falk was 32
when he retired and eventually joined
nfl network and was excellent at it and
still is excellent at it he's a regular
wednesday guest on my rich eisen show
football season coverage
goes on right now i should mention in a
cross-promotional manner
but
he marshall has a sense of drive and
understanding a professionalism and
understanding about broadcast television
and what makes it a good comment to say
this or not that and understand that if
you are saying this your colleague on
the air will be put in that position to
follow up or you need to give that
colleague space to talk and there's a
certain broadcasting sense and
sensibility and having a thought in your
head and how to verbalize it it is a
craft and it takes time and it takes
work and it takes professionalism to do
and many
nfl players that i have worked with in
auditions where many times for nfl
network i would i'd just be the only
host so when it was some player that was
just retired they wanted to see if that
player could work on the air that player
would come in for an audition and i
would sit next to them the number of
times where they thought these players
coming off the field thought that their
name
and credibility as a football player
would be just enough for them to get on
tv
i lost track
there's a certain ability that you have
on the field
that needs to be translated in a
manner on the air
with your language
and your
persona
that not a lot of players have and they
think it's easy to talk off the top of
their head and it's easy to take their
football knowledge and make it
communicable to a fan at home
and that's why so many players can't
succeed coming off
of the field they can't also some
athletes who come off the field who
don't succeed
don't succeed there was a basketball
player
back in the day at espn
um
and the only hint i will give is this
player played in the
um northern part of california you can
figure out from there
he was terrific as a player and also
terrific in the meetings went on the air
and he couldn't put
a sentence together it was difficult for
him to make a communicable
sentence of an idea that he knew as a
player
and he knew as a person
and he knew as a colleague in the
meeting but couldn't say it on the air
and after a while i realized the reason
why he could not
is because he worked blue in the
meetings
and he would lace his comments with
curse words
and then when you get on the air you
can't do it
i'm serious there are so many different
reasons why an athlete doesn't translate
successfully to television
and the fact that strahan has done it so
seamlessly
yes it helps to have a hall of fame
resume although
you know nate burleson's not going to go
into the pro football hall of fame but
he is doing the strahan plan he's on cbs
this morning right now and he's going to
start branching out you're going to see
nate everywhere if you already have it
and yes it helps to have a hall of fame
resume but it's not a requirement and
yes it does happen to help to have a big
personality that people like hearing
from you that you have a friendly face
you have a very
uh personable aspect you're charming
that helps
but what sets people like strahan apart
and so many others that i've worked with
from marshall and michael and
kurt warner
is a
a sense of professionalism this is work
this is work and yes straight hands got
an espn plus show and a men's clothing
line and a game show and so on and so
forth and he has a team he has a team of
people who help him out and schedule him
and tell him here and there and he's
probably getting the schedule in the
morning this is what you're doing today
and his phone does ring off the hook and
i'm sure people make phone calls on his
behalf but it's work
it's work
and he is willing to put it in
the work put the time in the work the
professionalism the work
it's a craft and i think that's part of
what i i'm hoping you gain out of this
um
podcast series that the work that we're
talking about broadcast and sports
broadcasting and nfl sports broadcasting
which is
you know uh uh a golden ticket to use a
wonka phrase
in in the profession and it is
something that is a labor of love and it
is something as straight hand said and
something that i will always say lucky
very
fortunate certainly in this time and day
and age where the nfl everything
to do with the nfl is a saga it's a
drama it's uh it lights up a phone line
on a on a daily
show it gets a remote clicking to it
or click on a link
but it's work and strahan's putting that
time in and you could tell
and
i just wanted to stress that and
reiterate it as we wrap up this show
um
about yes a hall of fame athlete who
made something of himself from a small
school
going to a big city and utilizing the
platform that the big city afforded him
in his super bowl season
along with his
hall of fame
trajection and his playing career but he
made that opportunity work
and one opportunity that came he wasn't
satisfied with just the one opportunity
there was another one that interested
him and another one and another one and
he says yes to those and he says no to
others and he's got people who help him
but he knows every single time he says
yes
it requires more work
and the fact that he knows that
um
going in and that it's not just i'm
michael strahan i've got a big
personality it's gonna work
he knows as he said once you get in the
room you use your face to get in the
room and your resume to get in the room
and you're recognizability to get in the
room but it's what you do in the room
after that
that keeps you there
and that'll wrap it up for this edition
of just getting started keep on checking
it out right here on the cumulus podcast
network there were so many other great
episodes before this one and some more
to come here on this voices of the nfl
edition of just getting started
[Music]